foreign
I am literally crying
I'm just so freaking funny oh boy I haven't
cried from laughter in a long time what is
going on there citizen my God my hair is still so
wet it is wet hair today what is going on there I
could have just waited like another 15-20 minutes
but we'll go with the wet piece I was just in the
mood for a comedy you know uh and I was just
like like what's on my list that is a comedy
and this one stood out to me I remember the
trailer sort of and I remember being like ah
it looks funny and I just never watched it so
I was like all right yeah let's let's do this
one I hear it's kind of an underrated film 17
Again made sure to wear my French shirt because
of Sir Matthew Perry yeah go ahead leave a like
I would really appreciate that also subscribe
click that notification Bell because we got
other movie reactions that we've been doing
it for the Chanel full-length Reaction watch
alongs I'm acting like this is the first time
I've ever said this information but you might
be damn full-length reaction watching long
story sync up with your own copy of 17 again
I'm gonna watch this on Netflix actually uh
available for our super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page and over there we cover
a bunch of shows exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch along is included but
you could also find the rest of the watch alongs
over there let's see what all the hype is about
class of 84.
Zac Efron's so much more buff now when he
was already in shape really good shape he
looks so skinny compared to today I'm just
warming up coach just talked to the Scout
again he's coming at night he's prepared to
offer you a full scholarship Jim Gaffigan is
so funny I'm glad you're here scar this
whole Scout thing is me wicked nervous
oh my God is she pregnant
oh no
this is so much heavier already than I expected
she is preggers wow Mike what are you doing Julie
we're in this together oh this is
so sweet dang that's your future
and told me this is gonna be so
touching it's only like two minutes in
hey I'm a sucker for that kind
of [__] man that's really sweet
you know not that Matthew
Perry is a bad looking guy
because he's not but to go from Zac Efron
into Matthew Perry you're looking at Scarlett
kicking you out of the house and the kids want
nothing to do with you as a negative when in fact
I guess it's mostly negative
you're getting that big promotion
today right yes yes I am
today everything turns around for me
see knock them dead that Thor in the
background I feel like this movie was a
good choice the way corporate wants us to
spin it is that maybe in certain situations a
four-hour erection isn't such a terrible thing
laughs so congratulations Mike yeah
Mike if you could just slide to your
left so I can congratulate our
new RSM Wendy you just slide here
Mike O'Donnell sooner or later you
all come back to the old school
stand there and look at the picture of
the Glory Days wonder what might have been
well of course I want to live
in the past it was better there
I'll bet you wish you had it to do all over
again is he gonna Grant this wish basketball
season's coming up you ready yeah remember it's
not how big you are how big you play right up here
is that the theme of the movie kid actors
like Sterling something or another isn't he
destroying our yard it's not our yard it's my
yard I'm gonna turn it into a showpiece for my
clients clients of what landscape design the
way I remember that is that you spent about an
hour working on it and then you spent the next two
days complaining about if you had gone to college
then you could have hired someone else to do it oh
man look try to see things from my point of view I
am extremely disappointed with my life yeah but I
did you don't have to do many more favors then oh
she's great at playing people in troubling
relationships oh Mike you're gonna learn to
appreciate the present towards the
end of the movie get off of there
it is raining so hard hello hello
whoa
oh cool
it's such a nerd
oh no he'll be fine oh wow I feel great
don't use Excalibur
you have an understanding testicleable this is not
a bad uh impromptu lightsaber fight they're having
oh
my God
we're looking at your basic spirit guide
Transformation Magic the hero uh is transformed by
his spirit guide to set him on A New Path which
is what what do I look like your spirit guide
you know what to do abandon your family go back
to high school I'm going back to high school
man net this is my chance this is my chance to
have my life over but to do it right it's much
bigger it's about you oh yeah this is
this is cool this is hip to the picture of
Kevin Federline wearing the exact same thing
as little as possible hey watch
where you're going to a bag Stan
he's gonna be an important character I'm Jane
Masterson principal here at Hayden High hi
she looks very familiar she's not from
the office is she I think her hands just
made a baby excuse my dad he's not
used to talking to attractive women
well thank you for that uh flattering
yet totally inappropriate comment
it's about to say I'm single and I'm very rich
okay did you bring your transcripts oh yeah
I think Hayden would be lucky
to have you welcome thank you
your hair is pretty thank you would the lady mind
if I smelled it oh my God I don't date my students
parents okay well maybe I should tell you that
I never don't not date the principal of my child
and the least I can do is make sure that my
fake son doesn't look look like a total douche
look like a douche douche he's
hurt as good background say it
I would not drive that kind of car to high school
where the hell are you do you take any of this
seriously I'm a lot closer to them than you think
let's reschedule I hope she's not attracted to him
kid oh my God he's still here we're looking for
a point guard oh yeah let's come to tryouts okay
all right I'm done talking yeah you're still
gonna turn into Matthew Perry in a few years I
need you to get in trouble just enough trouble so
that the principal needs to meet with your father
yeah okay well we'll see uh can
I get a little help in here Alex
oh he's bullied uh your uncle Ned's kid I just
started here just just yeah just go for it
I guess they're really bond with him no no she's
the uh she's the head cheerleader I should never
go out when I first met your mother I was so
nervous I met my mother What You My Mother
yeah you just said the first time I Met Your
Mother yeah oh that's weird is your mom hot dude
yesterday shoved me in the washing
machine in my own house what was that
jerk doing at your house like it's
Maggie's boyfriend oh my goodness
oh my goodness this just keeps getting worse
and worse I'm very disappointed in your sister
I wanted you in the cafeteria I would have taped
you to a lunch lady you don't talk to him that way
what are you gonna do oh my God I'm so invested
in this right now I'm gonna call your father
heads up nicely done Sigourney
Weaver Alien Resurrection
too easy to say stand praise in
the week simply because he's a h
see according to Leading psychiatrists
stands a bully for one of three reasons
one oh my God he's so cool
with that ball Stan's brain is
underdeveloped therefore Stan is unable
to use self-control and the third reason
Stan has a small wiener oh [__] that
would hurt today in the 30s age group
damn way to show him up what did you learn
at school today that I'm a bad dad what are
you talking about I thought it was going great
it was going fantastic for me and then and and
then what that is a really disgusting sandwich
man but I think I was wrong about my spirit path
it's not about basketball it's about helping
Alex and Maggie there we go what was that
three-pointer oh my God he's actually good at
basketball what's he doing a little pressure
you're your Father's son I'm gonna get you on the
team that's it that'll that'll solve everything
what really matters is that
you're there for your children
Michael yeah exactly Mike I've never heard of the
guy ow hey Mom this is Mark Uncle Ned's bastard
wow you look just like my husband weird did you
see that I did I did you're gonna go to jail lady
I mean I know that you need to grieve a
relationship it's only natural okay you wait here
you need to hook up with someone new oh no
you look turd mother who is still married
by the way is planning on running around
with every guy you can get our hands on If
This Were Afghanistan she'd be dragged
through the streets by goats with her
hands cut off I'm just saying Naomi Naomi
I don't care uh huh they're the same person
be continuing our discussion on human sexuality
and as we discuss the official school policy is
abstinence now that is very sensible I'm glad that
someone here has their heads screwed on straight
hair you for safe sex now so
please take one and pass it down
you serious did I do that it's called making
love isn't it maybe I'm old-fashioned but I I
think that means that you do it with someone
you love and preferably when you're married
turn it into a baby because that's what love is
it's the first moment when you hold your baby girl
and you didn't know that anything could be so
small oh no is he gonna cry delicate and and you
feel that tiny heartbeat and you know that you
couldn't love anything more in the whole world
is she attracted to him well I'm so
worried about what's gonna happen
this is like a reverse situation
of big and Back to the Future
oh god dude
I'm gonna go to jail again
hey you can go to the principal's office now
talking you think that's going
to work I think it's just mine
it's gonna work oh wow yeah obviously I still
have a lot to do he's doing a phenomenal job
to put a pond in over here and a flagstone patio
there with sod in between then to have twinkling
lights above the whole thing so that every night
is a starry one it's gonna be amazing scar score
don't call her score I realized that whole
lady Cougar Hunting the mothers I'd like to
you know whatever it's called MILF thinking
more along the lines of business experience
college application but if you want to go there
that's okay so I'll just get you a shovel then
yeah okay time to seduce make things a real real
unclear area where we are the age appropriateness
oh my God he's even rekindling his love
wow that's hyper aggressive but she
is an unusually hot principal what
happened at the tryout tryouts it was
good Mark Mark had a great tryout he
played great and so did I made
the team so good I'm so proud
Zac Efron is so funny it's not fair again you
look like him and you're that funny it's not
fair what do you think it's amazing when people
see this when people see how talented you are
you could be designing Gardens all over the city
I have a date tonight I have to go you have a date
it's ridiculous because I'm a terrible
dancer so I'm an amazing dancer what
stop talking you just look
like you can move um foreign
that was a very hot dance when you
were one teach it to me I can't try me
no this is so bad this is so confusing what
does it say about her if she hooks up with him
you stand here okay like that I'll stand here no
you're picking that up pretty quickly mention
your husband do you think you guys are ever going
to get back together um no why are you so sure
maybe there's something he could do to fix things
mom yeah
she's nervous it's creepy right a
little bit she's so old it's like
mind him that he needs to be there on the
27th okay thank you no you gotta win her back
or be 17 and sleep around High School which
would then be creepy in context because you're
not actually a 17 year old I used to date the
most beautiful girl in school and I let her
slip through my fingers but I'm not gonna
let that happen to you you're right you're
absolutely right I'm just gonna walk up to her
and then respect yeah yeah tomorrow at school
the mentality goes right Maggie's not here but
um I am and I'm really really glad you came
it's my birthday I didn't get you a present I'm
sorry I'll just have to unwrap you hey hey I was
kicked off the cheerleading squad for being
too flexible okay okay sit down just sit down
those don't respect yourselves then how
do you expect anyone else to respect you
right don't respect me no don't respect me you
don't even have to remember my name oh my God
I'm just I just I just want to
tell you that you look like my dog
what did you just say she's a sweetheart
she died so I look like you're a dead dog
don't worry about it really people care Alex
yeah oh my God you know my name you're on fire
really literally how'd this happen literally
on fire oh no okay I'm gonna get out of here
don't let anyone record you Stan got
on the management track at Home Depot
oh great and I'm going to Westward
Community College to be closer to him
he's my forever he's gonna cheat on you in this
movie You Think I'm Gonna Let You mortgage your
future you're gonna let you throw away
all your hard work I forbid you to see
him anymore oh okay who the hell do you think
you are my father hey how'd it go fantastic
you're botching this
what are you doing let's
oh no oh no he's falling apart he's getting
too mad this is actually really well done man
damn he's so good oh
so happy for him
oh my God she's hugging him oh my God it's working
I'll buy every student a laptop you would deny the
children of laptops Miss Masterson the children
okay oh my God that's awful but this is not a
date no in no way a day and if I do this you
will stop the inappropriate behavior and gifts
and we're just going to drive to this restaurant
we're not going to fly there in the space shuttle
I don't want this movie to end get to
another chance how how are you gonna do that
Victory board in my house
smart call Stand double to be what did
he do he took me behind the quad and we
can't hear this you didn't
why that's why you dumped me
when you're young Everything feels
like the end of the world it's not okay
beginning you're gonna meet a boy
who treats you the way that you deserve to
be treated do not turn your attention to him
I know so I don't know what happened right now
okay I was looking for you I wanted
to invite you to my party I don't know
if you want to come tonight yeah I would
love to yes thank you that's very exciting
oh this is bad let's reverse
Back to the Future foreign
just trying to impress you okay and
the kind of guy who spends 10 grand
on Gandalf degrees Quarter Staff from The
Two Towers yes that does make you a dork
especially since Gandalf the Gray was only in
Fellowship he returns in two towers as Gandalf
foreign I am literally crying
I'm just so freaking funny
oh boy I've haven't cried from laughter in a
long time Jesus Christ you can have the nun
and put out anyway you know on second thought
because I know how to throw a punch oh my God
is he gonna Wake Up Older I was 17. I was back
in high school it's all the way back to the
future I know why you didn't want me to be
no no no no I'm hungry lioness
and you're a baby gazelle
Maggie I'm not the person I'm not the person
just say you're gay man what are you saying
are you confused I'm very confused yeah
I'm not gay I'm in love Maggie I'm I'm in love
you tell your girlfriend she put close eye on you
wow okay blast glass
ES
oh my God it's happening hi
we're great she's cute come on I'll
show you where just walk upstairs ah
everybody
this party is over
oh he's gonna have his kiss mom this
has been a really tough time and
and you really feel like part of the family
oh no no don't no no if you want to listen to
me I am the father of your children Scott let
me explain don't don't call me that you are a
weirdo little man child can't explain this you are
a pervert no no it's all falling apart All Is Lost
I'm sure now you can see why I
don't date my students parents
oh oh Mike Mark you have done effed up I had
no idea that it was gonna get so out of control
okay now I'm sorry I guess I deserve that
second one was on call for I'm sorry
are you okay I'm really sorry man
that looks painful no maybe they don't need
me anymore but I need them you're not to be
a buzz kill but um you're due in court in 22
minutes I have to stop this to the netmobile
I've got a letter here from Mike O'Donnell
he's the husband in this case no I'm sorry
Mike but we're in the middle of Runner if
it's okay I'd like to hear the letter please
it's smart that they made her
recognize him to look like her husband
I want to remind you of September
7th 1988. you were wearing a Guns
and Roses t-shirt I remember thinking
that I had to have you or I'd Die
then you whispered that you
loved me at the homecoming dance
and I blamed you for my failures and I know that
you think you have to do this today I don't want
you to damn heck everyone's so good in this
movie if I love you I should let you move on
no kiss that 17 year old boy you
know he was telling the truth
you'd know it she knows
that is so sweet [__] oh boy
it has an emotional thing to do
that's clever
oh
this movie
he is really good at basketball got a little
inside info for you Scout from Ohio State is
back oh my God playing college ball next year
huh that's the plan coach yeah the picture time
this guy was in this exact position
20 years ago I understand but I am
I am the prince of the principal and I
cannot be seen with my students parents
how can you be seen with me when
I'm wearing a cloak of invisibility
you can plunder my dungeon
anytime I'll bring my longbow
this movie's so touching
I've really been trying not to cry
this is soaked
it's a classic transformation story guy
make the same Choice again it's your turn now
love it if you were to do it all over again he
would this is the best movie I've seen all year
he's Matthew Perry you didn't have to come
after me again yes I did because I love you
you're the best decision I ever made I just forgot
look I I know that I've been in a bad mood
for the last 20 years I thought I wanted a
second chance at life but now I know I
just want a second chance with you yeah
yeah
I missed you does he realize he's turned back ah
this is a touching ass film
this was a lot easier before
checking me out I want Taco Bell pick up all my
stuff and I wanted to give you a key back and say
thanks it was hey whoa no no wasn't expecting to
see you there principal Masterson you look very
pretty health is yours so I guess I'll be seeing
you at work boss oh yes coach O'Donnell and
um we are very happy to oh I was thinking
over the coach's job yeah a little something
for your first day at your new job
don't think about how much it cost
it's got me a whistle don't blow it YouTube
love you I said it back
best movie of the year or whatever
that was came out 2009. ah I love
the hell out of that film that was that
was so good I was so good Jesus Christ
so blown away right now
I I I got moved to tears out of turning down
the brightness of this TV I got moved to tears
from just how touching and sweet it was then I
got I I I don't remember the last time I mean in
real I remember the last time in real life I don't
remember the last time on the camera pointed at me
that I I cried out of laughter that that [__]
was so funny like it was just so good freaking
Zac Efron you know I I don't think I ever saw an
actual Zac Efron movie until neighbors you know
like I had that kind of I remember watching uh The
Dark Knight when it came out and in the theater
like here is my association with Zac
Efron he was like he was that kid from
High School Musical and I've never
to this day seen High School Musical
and so when The Dark Knight was playing they
played a trailer for The theatrically released
High School Musical 3 and everyone in the
theater like I didn't boo because I didn't I
don't know I had no investment into the hatred
for it or whatever but everyone started booing
and so that was my association with what to think
of Zac Efron at like 18 years old that's is that
kid is that kid so I think that's partly why
I didn't see this movie because I just kind
of had that like it's probably just some like kids
movie or some [__] and so the first movie I ever
saw of him was um uh neighbors and I thought he
was hysterical in that film and it did have that
feeling of man he's one of those like athletic
ass like a Chris Hemsworth like you're you're
so charming and athletic and you're all so funny
like he's just the whole package son of a [__]
it's like leave some for the rest of us but
he didn't hear and watching him at uh uh even
before then you know when he's still playing
like you know real kids like high schoolers
I thought he was excellent he he he
hit just that right pitch perfect note
and you know like I love that you you do get to
see his display of like athleticism especially
with a basketball that's right in that High School
Musical trailer that we're playing it's basketball
a big part of that movie I've never seen any of
it so I don't know so he strikes me as the kind
of guy who'd just be naturally great at basketball
I mean shows in this movie but he it struck that
right pitch of being that he did everything like
him and Matthew Perry actually complimented each
other so well it felt like a full-on character
like he wasn't just playing the comedy if that
makes sense he was actually being the character
he was being the the older might keep like he had
to play someone in the high school later I know
he probably wasn't in high school people usually
play older to younger people are usually older
than they play younger and he had to play like
the actual adult version of Mike internally who
wants to be young and I thought it might have
been one of those movies going in where it's just
about reliving The Glory Days and just recapturing
that magic of what it was like to be popular in
high school again and then eventually go down the
predictable path of appreciating what you actually
have but it took such a different direction than
what I was expecting like it full on became you
know reversed Back to the Future where instead
of Marty McFly helping out you know his dad and
then the mom falling in love with him like the
opposite turn of it's like the daughter's falling
falling for him and and you know you've seen the
movie so yeah as if it's going I was so surprised
by the different path it was taking and I love
how they kept the fact that he was an adult like
he wasn't hooking up up with anyone he wasn't he
didn't even seem tempted to and those fatherly
qualities like the Mike O'Donnell adult father
the Matthew Perry within him would would come
out in conversation but it wasn't like a Beat
to Death kind of joke it wasn't like a one note
joke they kept doing it felt very human he felt
like a real person as opposed to Zac Efron just
doing the comedy bits of there's an older man
inside of me like that's what I'm really playing
he he played like the confidence the dumbfounded
part the fatherly quality like he did it it was
so natural and unbelievable and felt lived in and
that's such a big part of what made the comedy
sing so strongly like even his relationship
with uh what's his name Thomas Lennon should
I pull up the IMDb in case I forgot her name
for a situation like this yeah Thomas Lennon yeah
hilarious actor by the way Thomas Lennon uh like
even that relationship between him and Thomas
London like you see Matthew Perry and him in
the beginning and like yeah the same age okay it
makes sense and then it didn't feel like a younger
guy interacting with an older actor you could
still feel that friendship and camaraderie like
they even had great chemistry together in the Zac
Efron form and Thomas London's net gold like while
I think Thomas London is a hilarious guy he's
he is a hilarious guy has a lot of Versatility
at first his character I thought was
uh he might be a little bit annoying
like he's not that funny and this this nerd
thing is is a little uh it's it seems like
sketch writing right but as even as that went
along it became like that was my breaking point
when the principle was speaking to happen to each
other because it was already like so funny and
then it just got so hiding in that moment and
such a such a great way of doing the as opposed
to just discovering that they're both nerds the
reveal of that was hilariously done it I admire
the cleverness of how they captured it and and uh
and even his character I was so endeared and so
connected to his character and their friendship
and then even by the end when he says love you
and then Matthew Perry finally actually says
it back you're like ah yeah this is great this
is hilarious this is so it's so sweet and they
the the connections all around because it's a
family it's it is kind of like Back to the Future
it's weirdly a family movie at the end of the day
you know like the friendship that he forms
with his son Alex and helping him out through
the basketball I do like that Alex did get
a chance like by the time he actually made
the battle it's like oh my God I'm cheering
for this guy I'm really rooted for Alex too
I think they did all the Beats they landed at
I think that's what what impressed me the most
about this comedy they landed at all the Beats
you'd expect them to land at but you know you've
always heard that phrase right of it's not about
the ending it's about the destinations about the
journey and I think that's what this movie
excelled at was yeah the destination of all
these things is where you like from the beginning
of this movie where you'd sort of expected to land
but the way they got there was done in ways that
were unexpected to me and ways that kind of you
know had moments Rose kind of on edge because when
they are doing the the daughters uh you know when
uh oh my God hold on there's a reason I got IMDb
up here I'm so bad remembering it uh teen Scarlet
no no no no Scarlet teen is younger
Scarlet what the hell is that Maggie
uh when you have Maggie and and and uh mark
and the sexual tension happening on her and
man that was just putting me over the edge
and even like I liked how they had fun like
sometimes they the the the phrase that comes
to mind is like it feels like sometimes we're
playing with fire because even when Leslie Mann is
you know clearly drawn to Zac Efron in this film
it creates that interesting play with the
audience of okay we know what's going on but
from from the observational standpoint they're
like this could be like a really icky situation
because she doesn't know that he's really
like maybe something inside but she doesn't
really know and and she doesn't know that
that's really her husband she thinks it's
a 17 year old kid so she starts hooking up with
it like that could be a really like icky thing
and but you also like kind of want them to have
that chemistry because you know the reality of
the situation and you know what what Mark is
aiming for in this moment or or Mike is aiming
for uh to win her back man Zac and fern is so good
in this film he is so goddamn good you know what
you you know what they're aiming for so playing
with that fire I thought made for a really fun
Dynamic like Leslie man's always great you know
Judd Apatow's wife she's more than just shut
up she's a wonderful comedic actress wonderful
actors and uh I I thought like her and Zac Efron's
chemistry everyone's chemistry in this film was it
was just High Praise I gotta confirm the principle
because wasn't she the uh like the the one who
was like the boss of Michael Scott in the office
Jan was her name Jan not Jane Jan Jan yes that
was her took me it took me a second to recognize
uh she was hilarious she she didn't really make
me laugh and like she was a good thing for Michael
Scott to play off of but I didn't really consider
her funny in that show but she was really funny
here she had some really funny stuff and I like
the acknowledgment of like because you know I
kept wondering like how far of the line would they
push some of some of the things they're gonna do
in this film you know would it go like super edgy
uncomfortable because they always Teeter right on
the on the right line they knew to Teeter on
the right line but never cross it never have
like Zac Efron hooking up with anyone and they
use that to their advantage like at the bowling
alley when they all are uh coming on a Zac Efron
so strong and he sits them down and talk to them
about respecting themselves I thought was so good
good they registering like surprising tension out
of moments you wouldn't expect it was more than
just because you know I I expected a laugh I I
think what I was sort of my my cynical mind before
going was just expecting you know certain hijinks
I guess like every scene is gonna be what's the
next comedy setup of this scene and we're gonna
go do that scene obviously setting up like
not necessarily A Sketch but a certain kind
of bit we're gonna do and they did so much more
than that they actually did real scene work and
they did real character development for all the
characters all around you know you did have Maggie
grown to her own and and to have the the path
for her at the end be like yeah we'll see what
the future holds and then obviously Alex's growth
for allowing him to be a basketball player and you
know that momentary hands off the ball to him and
now it's your time so good it's so great foreign
just kind of dazzled by this movie I'm really
uh I'm taking it back by how good it is
and of course you know obviously Mike's Mike's
obvious Arc of learning to appreciate today
and and you know themes of gratitude or
something that can really tug at my heart
but she like the the unexpected Romance of
certain moments like in the courtroom when
he's all I'm doing is recapping scenes I'm
not even really reviewing this we're just
recapping stuff when he's reviewing uh when
he's when he's uh in the courtroom and he's
acting like he's reading off this letter which
is recanting a memory and and then you find it's
just like this uh directions or something that
was that's what I mean by how cleverly written
this is I thought it was going to be you know
like oh she recognizes that that looks like her
husband's writing I thought it was gonna
be something something simple like that
and they did so much more with it to allow for a
good visual storytelling and I think this movie is
so much more clever than I was anticipating what
is it on Rotten Tomatoes I just gotta find out
the end-all be-all Rotten Tomatoes that's the one
this is the god of the opinion you should have 56
Croc of [__] this film is hilarious and much
more clever than you'd expect I don't care that
it's a formula Lake the execution of the formula
makes it an unexpected surprise I heavily disagree
as a matter of fact the top audience com right now
says this predictable but inventive that cannot
move will dally and super reviewer I could not
like I I could not agree more that is the best
way to describe it predictable but inventive
and it hits all the predictable notes you had
to want it to hit by the end of the journey but
the way they get there I think makes for a really
touching endearing experience uh and it was it
was like I thought it might be cheesy and dumb
and it got better as it went and I'm not exactly
sure when the stride really hit because it was
always like entertaining and amusing to watch
there was a certain point where it was just like
consistently really engaging and really funny and
once it found out about really strong flow because
I feel like nowadays if you did a movie like this
it would just be set up for a comedy scene let's
look at our uh you could you could just imagine
like four riders in a room and they they all have
their index cards and be like oh for this this
sketch we could do this scene you know something
like Ryan Reynolds and Jason Bateman in the change
up something that just feels very bit heavy but
they let EV I think that's the the key to this
film is that they let every comedy every comedy
scene every really funny scene you know was still
somehow imbued in the characters and and sort
of advancing the the story and the plot of the
characters that they did such a good job at that
as opposed to just set up sketch and then insert
characters there and another thing I thought they
did well was they they took the right time
to let certain scenes be serious instead of
having a serious scene undercutting it with a
joke they allowed like not a lot but there were
certain scenes that they really let the drama
kind of hit you in the fields and that makes
it when it does go all comedy work even stronger
because yeah this film I thought had a great heart
and a lot of wonder and I loved it personally I
would say this is one of my most favorite things
I've ever been that ever done a reaction to this
[__] was awesome I love the hell out of it what
do you guys think about this film leave your
thoughts down below because damn that was uh
I feel you know what it is you know
what okay this movie came out in 2009
I'm gonna I'm just gonna do I'm gonna give a
guess here because maybe I'm just be like okay
High School Musical 3 was the year before this
came out and I remember there was a time where
hating on Zac Efron was like the thing you just
did because he was part of High School Musical
and unless you're one of those people that grew
up with High School Musical at the age I was at
everyone at my age and older and maybe a little
bit younger than me was all about like kind of
hating on High School Musical like I said
I went to see the freaking dark night and
everyone booed in the theater and I feel like
that kind of played in to why this film probably
has a bit of a lower rating because this movie's
better than a lot of comedies that come out I I
personally think so I think it's a really well
I think it's a clever it's it's cleverly done
and I feel like I'm like a passionate defender
of this film now uh it is it is so much better
than a lot of comedies that do come out and I
think that because of the fact that Zac Efron uh
you know was just in High School Musical through
the year before that it was the natural thing to
kind of like shine a negative Spotlight or like
watch it through that kind of lens instead of
allowing yourself to be sort of Charmed by the
film that's what I'm gonna blame it on I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna let anyone have their own
subjective opinion I'm gonna say you're always
being a bunch of [__] because he was in high
school musical three dumb critics anyway we're
uh we're done now thank you thank you for
being here this was this was uh this is one
of the best things I need I I I I loved it I
really loved it thank you guys for being here